thank you
[Music]
lining users in anime are like the real
live version of the Energizer Bunny
these zappy characters are always
charged up and ready to go leaving their
opponents shocked and electrified so
without further Ado let's dive into the
times when lightning uses in anime
flexed on their opponents but before
that are you ready for the ultimate
sci-fi gaming experience introducing the
sponsor of this video honkite starl the
newest game from the creators of genshin
impact hoyo verse immerse yourself in a
world of mature art style and great
characterization with your favorite
characters from strong world leaders to
cunning strategists each character will
leave a lasting impression on you but
the fun doesn't stop there honkite star
rail offers an immersive experience with
its well-made music cutscenes animations
and more you'll be blown away by the
attention to detail in every aspect of
the game experience the richness of
anime based sci-fi themes as you travel
through different worlds each with its
own unique style and underlying science
fiction theme with each World offering a
new experience honkite starrell is the
game that keeps on giving and don't
forget about the turn-based combat
system too honka X Star Wars combat
mechanism is Rich and strategic allowing
for diverse gameplay experiences with
different combat combinations so what
are you waiting for the game's out now
so join the adventure and take on the
honkite in honka X star rail using the
link in the description we start off
with Hitomi in code breaker
Hitomi was formerly known as the
strongest among the code Breakers in
Eden with his potent electrical output
that was said to be strong enough to
melt iron coupled with his intellect
he's a foe that no code breaker should
take lightly in his confrontation with
all of the code Breakers we get to see
firsthand how he overpowers and almost
kills all of them entirely with the
maximum output of his electrical powers
despite them all working together to
bring him down he's still got the upper
hand at the end it was only due to
Sakura's negation powers that his attack
was rendered useless and saving everyone
else in the process with his cool and
laid-back personality he's the type of
antagonist that you just love hating
[Music]
next on the list is the Lightning Dragon
Slayer from the fairy tale guild LAX
Australia
yes
the fight takes place in in town
where Laxus joins forces with mermaid
heal and lamia scale to liberate the
town from Alvarez's Invasion axis
confronts worn after he injures his
friends from the Thunder God tribe with
puppet self-destruction the fight's
Fierce and brutal as War uses his
weakness magic to target laxus's heart
condition caused by magical barrier
particles he absorbed a year ago Laxus
manages to overcome his pain and unleash
his red lightning dragon mode which
allows him to use Dragon Force and
increase his power he then defeats war
with a powerful Roar that destroys him
completely using his opponent's attack
to his Advantage Laxus proves once again
why he's one of the most memorable
lightning users in anime
hello
Cornelius
[Music]
dashing through is electrifying Batman
from darker than black
PA and Wei are two contractors who
fought each other several times
throughout the series they both have
electrical abilities but way can also
create blood blades that can cut through
anything their final fight takes place
in episode 10 of the first season where
he ate manages to defeat Way by using
his own blood as a conductor for his
electricity the fight is intense and
dramatic as both of them are willing to
kill each other for their own reasons
just when we thought he was defeated he
manages to trick the sadistic Way by
using his pride in being undefeated
against him the irony of ways defeat
proves the intelligence and speed of the
black Reaper
[Music]
oh
the next one in line is none other than
the scaredy cat himself zinitsu
ES
with this fight against the brother
spider demon who sees in itsu at his
lowest trembling in fear as the toxin
that he was previously injected with was
slowly taking effect on him as he
reminisces about his past he starts to
notice the Venom start to take effect
which intrudes anitsu fashion causes him
to faint and lose Consciousness as the
brother spider demon takes pride in his
victory zinitsu takes hold of the flow
of the battle as he surprises the demon
with a sudden attack zenitsu struggled
at first seeing as he was only capable
of using a single technique but after
overcoming this weakness he reached the
conclusion that he merely needs to
perform that one technique that he's
capable of multiple times to make it
effective and thus Thunderclap and Flash
Eightfold was born utilizing this
technique zinitsu maneuvered around the
battlefield in quick succession and on
his final strike decapitated the brother
spider demon with his confidence now
replaced with utter fear his headlines
on the ground awaiting its demise a
truly well-deserved victory for our boy
next up on the list we have one piece
featuring NL
[Applause]
guys
us
in the world of one piece a lot of
really unique and sometimes weird
abilities really come into play and nl's
no exception with his Mastery over
lightning combined with his observation
haki NL can rain down lightning strong
enough to vaporize anything caught in
its path after detecting our protagonist
with his observation haki and L
immediately sets out to confront the
crew seemingly teleporting into the
scene and easily dispatching Sanji and
usop in a single attack with minimal
effort to boot without even giving them
a chance to retaliate or react he
threatened to do the same to the others
if they didn't comply with his demands
if that isn't called flexing then I
don't know what is he was just an
opponent that the crew was too
underpowered to face at the current
moment without Luffy's rubber-like
properties the fans would have kissed
the series goodbye at that point this
just goes to show how much of a threat
this guy is
up next on our list is the Last Stand of
Adolf Reinhardt against an army of
roaches
yesterday
[Music]
now cockroaches are very hard to kill
and even more so when they're six foot
tall humanoids living on Mars the anime
has shown the brutal war between
augmented humans and these evolved
roaches in gory detail one such likely
way to deal with the roaches is shown by
the second strongest member of the
colonists Adolf being augmented with the
powers of an electric eel of all things
Adolf and his team are ambushed by a
horde of cockroaches led by one with
electric power similar to his own Adolf
fights valiantly using his electric
shocks and hand-to-hand combat skills to
kill many enemies however he is
overwhelmed by the numbers and suffers
severe injuries he then decides to
sacrifice himself by activating his
self-destruct mode which releases a
massive amount of electricity that
destroys all the Cockroaches around him
he goes out with a literal bang as he
brings down lightning with a final
mocking gesture to the roaches
one of the most disrespectful Flexes in
anime comes from the king of syndria
Sinbad
[Music]
with seven Gins under his command
sinbads are forced to be reckoned with
as shown in his battle with itnan Sinbad
then activates his gin equipped ball
which gives him control over lightning
with balarok psycho Sinbad summons a
thundercloud and absorbs its lightning
into his sword he then releases it as a
powerful blast that destroys itnan's
puppet body the moment is impressive and
shocking as Sinbad demonstrates his
Mastery over Bar's power the finer words
of Vietnam with him lamenting as to why
such a person like Sinbad even exists to
begin with makes this moment that much
more chilling
the next one's a no-brainer Sasuke from
the last Naruto the movie which takes
place two years after the end of the
fourth Shinobi War
The Edge Lord appears in gonoha after
sensing a threat from toneri otsutski
who plans to destroy the world with his
dense Saigon as daenery sends a massive
meteor towards gonoha Sasuke uses his
susano and Chidori to destroy it with
one hand saving the Village from
Annihilation the Declaration that if
Naruto isn't available then he would
come to say the village is just
something only Sasuke can say with such
finesse we've seen him use Kirin and
indra's arrow in the past but seeing him
just use Chidori to obliterate the giant
meteor shows how powerful he's become
Sasuke not only flexed on his opponent
but also on his allies who witnessed it
foreign
it's mentioned that time and time again
that kiliwa is exceptionally good at it
even going as far as calling him a
prodigy
[Music]
with his ability godspeed greatly
increasing his speed and reaction time
to its utmost limit making its debut in
the Chimera and ARG where we get to see
this ability first hand kinawa's
opponent was none other than yupi who
was introduced in the setting as one of
the royal guards that was empowering the
protagonist by sheer power alone that
just shows how much of a threat he is
but despite that with Kilauea using
godspeed he somehow manages to make a
punching bag out of him overpowering him
with a flurry of attacks that even he
can't react to with kilowatt evading all
of his attacks using his immense speed
while all the while receiving hit after
hit but this slug first got put on hold
when killer whale ran out of juice and
with no other options he decided to
retreat despite kirua not winning the
fight the fact that he still went
toe-to-toe against someone who was in a
totally different realm of strength than
him was already a flex on its own
Series has always been jam-packed with
many Showcases of espers and their
unique abilities among them misaka is no
exception
with their efficient control over
electricity and the overall versatility
of a esper power it's no wonder why
she's on this list using her power over
electricity a simple object such as a
coin can be turned into a lethal and
effective attack aprily named railgun
this ability with the application of her
electric powers allows her to shoot off
coins in the same manner as a railgun
camp now imagine if she decides to use a
full-blown Mecca instead of the usual
arcade coins as ammunition in episode 24
of a certain scientific railgun s we get
to witness misaka use an all-purpose
Mecca to dispose of a missile that's
headed towards Academy City using her
efficient control over electricity she
launched the entire machine into the
missile destroying the whole thing in
the process the uniqueness of how she
uses her electrical ability is a breath
of fresh air in the anime genre I guess
she's not a level 5 esper for nothing
foreign
[Music]
and those are my favorite moments when
lightning users Flex on their opponents
we've explored the most electrifying
characters who have the ability to shock
stun all their opponents with their
lightning powers let me know what you
think in the comments section below
don't forget to check out honkai star
rail the Link's in the description glad
to have you here and thank you so much
again for watching this video